hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
i'm just checking it on you oh
[ __ ] how are you how's your week going
are you having a you're worried about
the covent
delta
unreal just when you thought it was safe
to go
outside whatever i i think uh
you know i'm not i have faith in the
doctors and i really believe that you
know if you really look
if you put this virus into a cinematic
form most sequels suck they're not as
good as the first one so i don't think
it's going to be as powerful
that's what that's what i'm hanging on
the hope for and i'm i'm i'm
rooting on the the medical community
that's what i'm doing i'm not focusing
on the person i talked to last night at
my show
who's like don't focus on the negativity
bro
i love the guy that's what that was his
response to i was going like what are
they saying now we got to wear masks
again there's another
covert and the guy's like don't focus on
the negativity bro
just shrugging his shoulders you know
that's one of the greatest [ __ ]
responses ever
you know zen comes in all forms and
sometimes it comes
in stupidity you know not saying the
guy's not good at math not saying he's
not going to do well in life but just
that
that small town you know i've always
been envious of people who
have like that small town mentality and
they're just happy as hell
and you know people in my business make
fun of them and i
they shouldn't because those people are
way
more happier than seekers
than people who want to travel and see
the world and find out
you know what their truth is and blah
blah blah blah
those [ __ ] people they grow up
in a town they have no urge
no need no desire no itch to scratch to
[ __ ] leave
they marry somebody who's of the same
mind that grew up in the same town and
blah blah blah blah
i mean
who's happier than those have you ever
met happier people
well why would i leave they got eddies
and murray's down the street
we go over here for the ice cream my
parents took me here
happy like i really think that
if you have a kid all right
in a small town and then the kid never
leaves the town and is totally happy
you [ __ ] crushed it as a parent like
the kid had no like
i have to make a name for myself i got i
got to do this i got to do that
then i'll be happy they're like no man
you know
grew up here i [ __ ] love it here
get myself a job putts around town
take the wife and kids out to the local
spot my parents took me to and that's
there's a [ __ ]
zen mentality that you have enough
you don't need more and uh
yeah i don't know and this kid had that
vibe but it was [ __ ] hilarious
to apply that small town to something
that was killing people globally
still one of my favorite things
somebody's ever said at one of my shows
yet he had his you know when you
interlock your fingers
oh and you got arrested on your hands
arrested on your head he was sitting
like that
leaning back don't focus on the
negativity bro
such a simple answer to such a huge
problem and what i loved about him was
he was trying to help me out
he was still coming from a good place
uh and you can what's funny is you can
get a small town mentality in a giant
city like los
angeles you can get it in new york city
new york city is probably has
per capita the largest group of small
town minded people ever
that i ever ran into and and all of
their bravado about you know new york
and how you got to be tough and blah
blah i don't know if they do that
anymore they [ __ ]
what they did to manhattan and now most
of brooklyn
um but back in the day when you had to
be tough and all blah blah
like if you want to see somebody
uncomfortable take a lifelong new yorker
out of new york
uh 100 outside of their
comfort zone and they just start they
start having like a [ __ ] panic attack
what if i want chinese food at four in
the morning hey how about you order it
at one
what if i want to go here until five in
the morning how about we just go out
earlier
you're still gonna drink for four to six
hours six hours is pushing it
you know it's still the same amount of
fun you're gonna have
nobody in new york would go out at seven
at night
and then stay out till six in the
morning unless you were doing blow or
something
but you can't do that legally right i
don't [ __ ] know anyway
so i've been having a great time i'm
recording this wednesday
afternoon 409 pm west coast time
51 minutes before game two of the
stanley cup final
between your tampa bay lightnings and
uh volt voltra [ __ ] uh
how do you say volt uh monreal canadians
however you say it right
uh tampa bay wins the first game
convincingly
i saw it when it was two to nothing and
then the canadians scored a goal right
at the end of the second period
and i was like okay here they come
because the whole time when it was one
to nothing i was just sitting there
watching it alone
saying all the cliches going they're
hanging around they're letting them hang
around
right and uh then all of a sudden
tampa scored again and i was like that
was a huge [ __ ]
goal that is a backbreaker right there
because now the game is almost
two-thirds over you just doubled your
lead
on that goal psychologically that really
[ __ ] hurts them and as i'm thinking
that bam
[ __ ] canadian score and that's why
they are in the final because it's a
[ __ ] great team
that i don't think is overachieving i
just think they're a great [ __ ] team
i hate to say it as a bruins fan but
they are and then i had to go out to go
do my show and then i saw
that the final score was five to one i'm
guessing
one of those was an empty netter but um
so obviously game two you know
the canadians have seen what tampa does
and i'm sure they've come up with a game
plan to try and shut that down
like they did to vegas like they did to
winnipeg
like they did for the final three games
against tampa i mean against toronto
can they do it against the tampa bay
lightning who are trying to be the first
team to go back to back
stanley cup winners since the 2015 or
2016-2017
uh pittsburgh penguins
not only that they're trying to bring
the third title to tampa within like a
[ __ ] year
this time last year a little over a year
because i guess before covid and
everything right
or last year was covert also i can't
even [ __ ] remember
i forget how that worked out they won it
in like sort of june julyish i imagine
and the uh tampa bay buccaneers with of
course tom brady you got tom brady's a
quarterback you're just gonna [ __ ]
win the super bowl that's just how it is
the man wins it every other year 2014
2018 2020. so maybe he doesn't win it
this year
he wins it the following year
um which i don't even have to look it up
and that's got to be a record 14
16 18 20. has anybody won four super
bowl titles every other year
for [ __ ] seven years
every other year maybe somebody's wanted
four no
you'd have to go to that who's that guy
that played on the 49ers
charles haley and the cowboys and dion
sanders jumped back and forth between
the 49ers and the cowboys um
anyway plowing ahead here so obviously
i'm rooting for tampa but i'm not taking
it to
a bruins county level that i'm not going
to enjoy
how great a team the montreal canadiens
are they're a [ __ ] great team
so uh we shall see in tampa bay
lightning looking to put themselves in
the history books
as far as uh one of the great teams um
in recent
memory as far as their [ __ ] dominance
um
and with that and with that
let's talk about how [ __ ] out of
shape i am
turning it around it's 187.2
after tipping the scales at i don't know
189 points something
tipping the scales and that was after i
hadn't eaten like i said in like [ __ ]
i don't know how many hours 14 hours 15
hours
maybe even more than that so i was in
the low 190s
which is just disgraceful because uh at
my height you know someone was saying
that the 200 pound threshold do you go
over that there's no coming back
i mean you can come back but you got to
get like skin operation after that and
they're going to [ __ ] start you know
hacking you down like shawarma
so my um my goal
is uh you know i just watched the four
kings
on uh showtime and i'm looking at marvin
hagler who is my height 5
10. i'm just under 5 10. five nine three
quarters do not lie about my [ __ ]
height on my dick size
marvin marvin hagler 510
159 that's what i weighed
when i graduated high school so that's
what i'm shooting for
because if i come up short i'll be in
the 160s and i'll still look [ __ ]
great
you know what i mean um so that's kind
of what i'm going for gonna try to lose
two to three pounds a week
for the next i don't know 19 weeks and i
think i should be there
i should be there let's see let's see
where it is and i'm saying this on the
[ __ ] podcast
so you guys can write in and give me
[ __ ]
and uh keep uh driving me along here so
um when did i weigh myself on the 28th
so i need to be 186 by june 5th
then 183 then 180 then 177
174 171 168 that's when it gets exciting
165.
162. 159. now if i can somehow
if i drop three pounds a week
i by september 6th
i will be in marvin hagler's shape i'm
not going to look like marvin hagle but
you know what i mean i'll be as bald as
him breast his soul um that's my goal
but you know what i'm
i'm i got a 10-day vacation in the
middle of that in august
so i'm gonna have to [ __ ] figure out
what i'm gonna be doing
because i'm going to be seeing some
friends
there's going to be local food that i've
never tried
and i got to watch out for that week you
know
if you can if you can have you know what
so i'm going to say september uh
i'll give myself september 13th
right instead of the first week it'll be
the second week
and then and only then
because you know 10 days if you could if
you could have a zero
week on a vacation didn't gain didn't
lose
that's pretty [ __ ] good i think i
don't know am i babbling
dude i'm so [ __ ] fat right now i
can't fit into any of my show shirts my
button-down fitted shirts
i deliberately have them that way so i
won't become a fat [ __ ]
and what happens is how i stay on shape
is if i'm wearing them on the road and i
feel like they're getting a little
[ __ ] uh
a little grabby you know i just hit the
i at the hotel gym i [ __ ] eat well
for a couple days and i
get i get the bloat to go down but the
thing is is i haven't had any road dates
so those [ __ ]
jerseys have just been [ __ ] jerseys
those [ __ ] uh
button downs have just been hanging in
my closet
and you know i've been [ __ ] in
sweatpants and [ __ ] like that and even
jeans jeans you know you buy jeans
they'll say [ __ ] 33 34-inch waist
but they'll stretch out to like 38 so
that's what i got 33
34 inch jeans that stretch out the 38
and they're actually
pinching on my hips now so i'm like a
[ __ ] 40 or something i got to be
every bit of a 40 a tree a true
honest 40.
because everybody's so [ __ ] out of
shape now that they
they they lie the pants are a lie
they make you feel better i can get it i
can fit into 34's yeah because it
stretches out to 38 you [ __ ]
don't donate eating [ __ ] or in my my my
case a cake eating [ __ ]
so um i am [ __ ]
uh
uh i am done with this [ __ ] i'm done
with it so i've been going on my old man
walks which i did today
walking around uh you know on leg day
i'll actually go on a hike i'll drive to
a park or something i'll go on a hike
one of the great things about la is they
got all these great places to go on a
hike but if it's just like uh um
a uh just a regular day where i need to
go for walks
and try to get my steps in which by the
way that [ __ ] [ __ ] that you need
to take 10
000 steps a day is [ __ ] horseshit
that's like five [ __ ] miles it's like
you don't need to walk
five miles a day if you're eating right
okay
if you're eating the way i ate over the
last six weeks you need to do about
[ __ ] 20
000 steps a day um but i was walking
around
um you know i like to drive places and
then go for a walk just so i can see
different parts of the city because i'm
not driving
by so i don't miss it you know i miss
[ __ ]
because i'm trying not to get cut off or
i'm staring at my phone texting like
most people when they're driving
trying not to do that but um so i was
walking around the city
and uh i came walking down the street
and there was this guy sleeping
sort of like in an l shape like his legs
were straight out and then his back was
up against the building
and he was sleeping and i walked by and
i was looking at him because i was like
thinking like there's a young guy how
the [ __ ] do you end up like that and as
i walked by him
he opened one eye and was looking right
at me
and i was just like oh [ __ ]
is this the guy now gonna jump up and
take out on me whatever made him [ __ ]
be laying there in the l position on the
[ __ ] sidewalk
uh but anyway yeah i just was uh
i don't know just walking around had a
couple of you know it's a lot of
homeless people out here in l.a now
because of uh
you know the kovid [ __ ] the
never-ending war we got veterans out
there and then we got like you know
what is it one percent of people own
like [ __ ]
some ridiculous percentage of the wealth
um
i actually ran into a real estate agent
out here last night the son of a friend
of mine
and um
i was asking him what where all this
money is coming from
that people are like it's like you watch
the news and they talk about what a
difficult time the average person has
been having during all of this [ __ ]
and then you go on zillow and this is
what you do on zillow
and zillow for the first [ __ ] two
houses you look at something you can
afford
and then you just go let's see what the
[ __ ] no limit looks like
so i was looking at that [ __ ] and like
all of these [ __ ] houses they're like
out here those houses like 25
30 40 50 80 million
and they all say like sold on well they
stay on the market very quickly it's
like who where the [ __ ] did that money
come from
he was like i don't know man i don't
[ __ ] know
um oh i want to post a video by the way
because for the longest time
you know i've been telling this story of
how i saw
david lee roth on the edom and smile
tour
with uh billy sheenan on base steve vi
and guitar
and greg bissonnette on drums i saw him
in 1986
and it was a big big big [ __ ] deal
it was a big deal for fans and it was a
big deal for that band
because david had gone his separate ways
from van halen
and um van halen was basically a super
group
that came together naturally it was just
everybody was [ __ ] amazing
eddie and alex van halen david lee roth
the greatest
[ __ ] front man arguably in rock
history
um and then michael anthony
who's like background vocals was such a
huge
part of the sound of that band so david
goes the second way
van halen gets sami hagar so they're
guaran so now you got these two camps of
unbelievable musicians that are now
going to compete with each other
and fans are going to go out and go see
both bands
and then say who's better so i think
they were already
like you should make they should make
like a [ __ ] movie about it
so anyway david lee roth coming out and
his his
his lead guitarist up until this moment
in his career
was you know up there with hendricks
jimi hendrix as far as like
when jimmy came along it was like this
nobody ever heard anybody play like that
they had come from like it was
like from like another planet and eddie
van halen was the same way
just completely changed how people heard
the instrument
approached it it was like
what the [ __ ] is this guy doing and then
how does he do it and everybody tried to
figure it out and then there was an
entire generation
um of people
trying to do their version of what eddie
did or what jimmy did and not
never coming close um
that you're either that guy or you're
not so david lee roth comes out
and his lead guitarist is a guy who came
up with zappa
so you know he's a beast steve vi billy
[ __ ] one of the sickest bass players
who could actually go like lick for lick
with steve vai
on bass and then greg bissonnette who i
believe was a jazz guy i remember
reading way back in the day
um in modern drummer you know him
talking about going to see big bands
when he was in the rock
and his dad or something took him to to
go see this show
and he was just like all right it's a
[ __ ] big band this is old people
music and he said when the band started
playing
you know what is a big band it's four
trombones four saxophones four trumpets
that's and then the drummer upright bass
piano player maybe a guitar player or
something like that
so that's 16 horns and he said when they
came out and they started playing he
said he almost fell out of his chair and
then he went down like that
jazz i don't know if he went to berkeley
whatever but just a monster player so
anyway i went to go see
uh this band in 1986 at the providence
civic center
uh it might have been the worcester
center but i think most of the shows i
saw was the providence civic center
right down 95 past attleboro wound
socket
um and they absolutely [ __ ]
destroyed and i remember people
at the show being like billy she is like
he's a way better player than michael
anthony
uh alex's fan greg president he's
[ __ ] good as out there
were talking about like during the show
like comparing him it was [ __ ] crazy
right
so anyways what has driven me crazy over
the years as a comedian was david lee
roth ever the showman
showman came up with this [ __ ] bit he
told this story about some kid
practicing a drum and the neighbor's
getting upset by it
and the bit had him and greg bissonnette
and it was a little
like one of those steel drums like the
jamaican drummers play right
and dave would tell this whole [ __ ]
story about this kid
and the neighbors yelling and then and
he said but every day the kid came out
he just kept practicing and he would
just say and then he played like you
know this whole little run on the steel
drum
and all i remember was the punch line
was in the end when the kid couldn't
take it anymore he just goes
david lee rob just goes hey [ __ ] you man
oh place went nuts went [ __ ] nuts
and uh so
this was what this is a show i saw about
35 [ __ ] years ago so lo and behold
last night
believe it or not uh greg came out to
the show i knew he was coming down
and he came backstage and i told him
about that bit he goes i can't [ __ ]
believe you remember that joke
he goes yeah it was a story about a kid
named raymond
he told me the whole [ __ ] story and
then he was nice enough to send me the
clip so i'm gonna post it
on the uh on the monday morning podcast
twitter
whatever the [ __ ] account is i don't
even know i'm gonna post that
i just want to thank greg for uh coming
out to the show being so [ __ ] down to
earth and cool and like telling me
like the whole story how he i mean he's
like a true musician because he was
telling me about the steel drum
he goes you go one way it goes up in
fifths and the other way it goes in
fourths and i'm saying
this is like i mean what that means
so anyway um
it really [ __ ] blew my mind
to meet him because i was thinking about
the like
eight i was 18 years old when i saw him
perform and if you ever told me back
then that someday i'd have the balls to
do stand-up comedy
and greg bissonnette the drummer from
this comedy bit that i loved and
was desperately trying to remember would
come out to my show and say i was funny
that's like the [ __ ] greatest thing
ever
so and a great dad too because he
brought his son on i could just tell you
can tell
you know when kids get past a certain
age and they can [ __ ] hang out with
their parents and they're cool like i
really look at that a lot now
and um i was looking at that going like
man
i gotta i really hope i have that kind
of relationship
my kids are like in their 20s and [ __ ] i
mean that's right
that's when you know you did it when
you're still going to a [ __ ]
ball game or something like that with
your kids when they're in their 20s and
you're laughing you're having a good
time and it's relaxed they're talking
you're listening
you know when you're talking they're
less listening it's
regular i got to do that i got to hit
the reset button
on my family tree uh i'm not really
almost like my generation how [ __ ]
nuts we were
so anyway other than that
i've been uh [ __ ]
i don't know if i'm ever gonna get this
instrument rating every time i think i i
climb the last mountain of information
that i need
but it's made me such a better pilot and
um
i've been flying these approaches dude
it's [ __ ] wild
it's [ __ ] wild just imagine flying
and you're not looking out the window
anymore because you're simulating uh
you know flying in the clouds so you
wear like these foggles and you tape
them up and everything like that i
haven't gotten to that point yet i just
sort of looked down and i'm just staring
at the gauges so i can almost see the
land
a little bit so i am cheating a little
bit but still
it freaks you out at first because
you're like what the [ __ ] i mean i am
supposed to be looking for traffic
and all of that [ __ ] but obviously i got
my instructor with me but you're looking
at
your six pack of gauges and
uh and then a number of other things any
you know
on mine i have a glass cockpit so
there's a little bar
that moves back and forth that keeps you
like lets you know if you're in or out
of trim
you got to look at that every once in a
while and anyway
you do these approaches and you either
have like a gps approach
which is you're using satellite or
you're using like ground
navigation nav aids or whatever like
that and some of them
are precision and some of them are
non-precision
when you have to do a precision one
which is the coolest one you have
lateral and vertical guidance and you're
trying to keep the cross basically
you're trying to keep it all like
your descent rate and everything where
you're not below the glide slope or
above it
and then you're also like laterally
trying not to be
you know have full deflection of the
localizer i know i'm using a lot of
[ __ ] terms here but it's
this is the [ __ ] that a dummy like me is
trying to learn so we were shooting
approaches the other day
and the coolest feeling ever is once you
hit like
you know your um
the missed approach point or the
decision altitude
um you look up and you're just [ __ ]
lined right up with the runway it's like
right there when i say
right there on a precision approach if
you did it right
you are literally lined up the center of
the [ __ ] runway
not even off to the left or the right
you could you mean
you couldn't do it that well if you were
looking on a clear day
and the fact that somebody figured all
of this [ __ ] out
and built this technology
is is insane it's just mind-blowing
and what i love now is i can get on with
approach
which to me was always the big boy radio
when you're just sort of flying vfr
which is just visual
you just sort of like you know you're
talking to local airports and if you
you're talking to like
uh sort of a common traffic channel
if you're in between air spaces of
airports
but when you get on with the approach
then you're talking to these people who
are
nowhere near you that are looking at
some big board and they're following you
and guiding you in
and there's these points that you're
flying to in the sky that are called
fixes and they they bring you down like
a staircase
right into the uh the runway
down safely and you get to a level
where you know uh on a non-precision i'm
saying this so i know for the
test at the uh missed approach
point you're allowed to fly that
altitude to us
for a little while until you see the
runway
or you do a missed approach on a
precision approach at the decision
altitude
if you can't see any runway markers or
the lights or anything like that you
immediately
do the missed approach which is on your
instrument approach plate
see this [ __ ] this is why it's taking me
so [ __ ] long with two kids trying to
learn how to do all of this stuff
so um been doing that and then yesterday
i
flew there was actual instrument
conditions
down around long beach so we decided to
just go
up to the hills even though it was like
hot out and we sort of um
i had about three quarters of a tank of
fuel and we went up there and we tried
to land
and um i should have anticipated it but
i i wasn't able to hold a hover
which is basically the weight of
your ship versus the density of the air
um because you can be at like 3000 feet
and on
a hot day the density altitude is
actually like 5 000 feet
so your aircraft is performing at the
level of if you were 2
000 feet higher so you really have to as
you come in be looking for the low rpm
light
and all of that type of stuff and uh it
was [ __ ]
unsettling but like i learned so much
flying that stuff so i don't know that's
what the [ __ ] i've been up to
as i've been walking these [ __ ]
trails and streets out here in la trying
to walk myself down
to where my show shirts fit me
i'll tell you something what i'm only
[ __ ] i'm bringing one shirt to vegas
for a two show night the two show
weekend
two night weekend three shows because uh
it's the only one that
fits me and looks all right the other
ones i can't [ __ ] wear it's
ridiculous like last night i wore a
[ __ ] t-shirt with a zip up in july
or june [ __ ] sweat my ass off on
stage i finally had to say like listen
i'm just out of shape i don't want you
guys looking at it um
and you know people like dude you look
fine you look fine i don't
okay i look fine with a shirt on i know
what i look like without a shirt on
i don't want to look like what i look
like without a shirt on with a shirt on
okay and then the next step is looking
like what i look like without a shirt on
with a [ __ ]
jacket on and then you're done and
that's how you become a tub of [ __ ]
and i don't want to all right so you got
to hold yourself to a [ __ ] standard
if you don't nobody else is gonna and
there's too much delicious [ __ ] out
there and it's so [ __ ] easy to put on
weight it's ridiculous
if i want to lose 15 pounds the right
way that's gonna take anywhere from
five to [ __ ] eight weeks
and you can put on 15 pounds in eight
days you could do it
you could go on well 15 is a little bit
much but you could put easily put on 78
pounds
on vacation posing order appetizers i'll
die away get back
there's just no [ __ ] exercise
that can outdo eating it's unfucking
believable
it's actually one of the few things that
makes me believe in a higher power
actually maybe
believe in a higher power but i don't
believe in one that cares
um it definitely doesn't care because i
even just look at the the food chain
if you just look at a bear that
something created
a bear that with all of its size
cannot kill its prey efficiently
you know what i mean it has to maul them
to death and begin eating them before
they're dead it's like why can't it be
like the cats
the tigers the lions the cheetahs
they just [ __ ] come except for a
house cat those [ __ ] play with their
food
torturous bastards there's some you know
what you know what cats house cats are
they got it's like little man disease
you know those [ __ ] short guys with
the napoleon complex i feel like
house cats have that same [ __ ] vibe
so they can't just kill a mouse they got
to show off and [ __ ] play with the
goddamn thing
um anyway but there's nothing better
than a cool cat so
i probably come down too hard on them
but anyway the fact that um
just sort of that law of doing the right
thing
is always harder and the feeling is
always better
versus doing the bad thing is always
easier
and then the feeling afterwards if
you're actually you know
not a sociopath is a horrible feeling
jesus christ how happy are sociopaths
they do the wrong thing and then they
don't feel any guilt afterwards
they don't feel any elation either but i
mean i don't know all right whatever
this is what happens when you [ __ ]
talk to yourself okay
this has been the podcast everybody um
you know if you're a [ __ ] tub of [ __ ]
like me too do this with me
try to lose two to three pounds a week
just keep going on your walks
i'm stopping eating like around five six
o'clock at night
i'm already used to doing that then i
just crush waters for the rest of the
[ __ ] night
and um
yeah and i'm just gonna be yeah right
around football season
baby
pick a goal and do it with me i'm going
for marvin hagler 5
10 159 and here's the thing
when i get down to like 168 my only
opponent at that point is going to be my
wife
she's going to you're getting too skinny
you got body dysmorphia you just just
[ __ ] eat something
and i'll be like one of those [ __ ]
army movie actors
playing one of those crazy guys not this
time
this time we win
this time i see it through
um all right sorry sorry to creep you up
all right everybody it's
babel four for most of us oh i'm sorry
it's babble
for most of us
i'm an idiot for most of us you can
laugh at me mia
for most of us learning a second
language is in high school or college
wasn't exactly a high point
in our academic careers now thanks to
babel
or as i call it babelfore babel
b-a-b-b-e-l
uh the number one selling language
learning app
there's an act addictively fun and easy
way to learn a new language
whether you'll be traveling abroad over
there or you just have some free time
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you can actually use in
the real world babel's 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way
to learn a new language on the go babel
designs
their courses with practical real-world
conversations in mind
things you get to use in everyday life
other languages
sorry other language learning apps use
ai for their lesson plans but
babel lessons were created by 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and accent
start your new language uh learning
journey today with babel right now
uh when you purchase a three-month babel
subscription you'll get
an additional three months for free
that's just six months for the price of
three just go to babel.com babbel.com
and use uh copy points promo code burr
b-u-r-r that's babel b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code burr for an extra three months free
babble language
for life okay uh listen enjoy the music
after this
uh rambling and then there's gonna be a
bonus
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast from a couple
years ago or however however
andrew the greek freak as paul verzi
calls them
feminists uh picks out the episodes all
right that's it have a great weekend
and uh you know tone into the stanley
cup final
um i think it's going to be a good
series despite how lopsided the first
game was we shall see
in 22 minutes my time all right
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday july 1st 2013.
oh my god is it july already i feel like
the summer's going by and i haven't even
put on
a strapless yet
i'll have another [ __ ] have another
vodka and [ __ ] something stupid drink
all right now why are all the wires
tangled up christ
this is no way to start a podcast
what's going on ah jesus [ __ ] christ
isn't this amazing just how
[ __ ] tangled up some [ __ ] can get
you know how does snakes do it it's
going around
they're basically like a [ __ ] mic
wire aren't they they could kill you
some of them sorry just gotta undo this
[ __ ] is this any way to start a podcast
is it
putting a [ __ ] windscreen back on it
i use a windscreen
inside all right so if you're new to my
podcast that's the level of intelligence
that you're going to be dealing with do
you think there's a snake
right if you're not poisonous
that's got to be like sucking at sports
you know for a human being and you go
into gym class
what exactly do you do if you're a
non-poisonous snake you mean you can't
[ __ ] grab anybody
because you ain't got no arms
what do you do what how does a
gardener's
garter snake was a gardener
oh jesus how the [ __ ] does a
non-poisonous
snake eat it just has to eat [ __ ] alive
just you know [ __ ] that isn't tougher
than it and it's just got to lash out at
it just
is the [ __ ] thing squirming around
god what a life you know and i tell you
you gotta commend
the the gartner or gardener or garner
james garner snake you really have to
commend them for
the um for their attitudes like you meet
them they're not they're not really bad
people you know what i think i'm gonna
do
i think i'm gonna write a thank you
letter
and i'm gonna put it in the [ __ ]
gartner snake garden snake whatever the
[ __ ] it is
newspaper and just thank them
you know just try and shine a little
light on the snake and then i'm gonna
sign it myself
dude what's the i i really have to
[ __ ] address this
right out of the gate i used to like the
blackhawks organization
i sat there through six [ __ ] games
watching that phenomenal team
basically kick the bruins ass i mean we
i mean
they beat us in six games now i know
there weren't blowout games but still
you know they just were better than us
and here i am
coming to the acceptance that we were
two games short that we were two games
to one
up you know three games in all we got to
do is split the next two
and we win it and we [ __ ] we didn't
we never win another game
lost three games in a row that's [ __ ]
tough
and then that ends nba's over and now i
have to somehow come out
of the high paced level of nhl hockey
the excitement of the nba finals to
like the dog days of summer baseball
hyatt inside
ball two daddy day for a ball game
if you're in town come down this
saturday this saturday
is uh hat with the propeller on it day
first 40 douche bags that show up get
one of these i don't know why you'd want
one but they're free so you know people
are gonna come
anytime it's free
all the fatties show up um so i'm
sitting here trying
you know to all right but it's a great
thing you know we're competitive we got
a great team we got a
great base that we can build on who
knows maybe next year right so
i'm starting the healing process of it
and what are these [ __ ] do
the chicago black ops they take out a
full-page ad
in like the [ __ ] boston globe and
this is the best part
rather than just saying oh by the way in
case you forgot
we kicked your ass in the stanley cup
finals these
[ __ ] [ __ ] have the nerve
to write a thank you letter
to the boston bruins organization
and to all their this is the greatest
thing ever classy fans
it was one of the biggest douchebag
deuce chill inducing events
in sports i since i don't know when
since maybe lebron james
the decision can you [ __ ] believe
that
first of all first of all let's just act
like this was sincere
and this was not grandstanding by the
chicago
blackhawks organization to just shine a
light on them so everyone would be like
gee
why aren't those guys classy isn't that
swell
because that's basically all that letter
achieved
okay i don't want to speak for the
entire bruins fan base but
we don't need a [ __ ] pat on the head
telling us we're classy but you [ __ ]
brought eating
[ __ ] out there with your freddie
mercury mustaches
the [ __ ] do you think we need that for
we played a seven game series it only
went six
you were the better team our team shook
hands with your team
it was it classy thing do you [ __ ]
believe
the balls on those [ __ ] blackhawk
[ __ ] can you believe first of all
i want you to find an article out there
because i know all the blackhawk fans
were like it was a classy move they were
they were saying thanks to the brewer
they didn't have to do that
let me ask you fat open heart surgery
[ __ ] out there huh every
nine out of 10 people out in chicago
have that zipper scar right up the
middle of their
fat [ __ ] torsos
all right and i was nice to them the
whole [ __ ] playoffs
playoffs right dude i want you to find
one [ __ ] article
out there about the blackhawks thanking
the bruins
that actually has the writer then
talking about like wow
what a great organization the bruins are
man their fans are so classy
the blackhawks actually had to address
it a week after the series was over
what is it about the bruins organization
that makes them so classy marv
well i gotta tell you ever since the
days of eddie shore
i want you to find one of those articles
because i'll tell you there's not one
all that letter of apology did
was facilitate more [ __ ] praise
for the blackhawks like when you can't
believe these guys i mean they
they they they they they win the the
stanley cup at
the state they have the intestinal
fortitude
around a lot of [ __ ] that [ __ ]
horseshit just heaping more [ __ ]
praise on him
it was actually it was a brilliant move
by them
you know what i mean you know what it
looked like like that they looked like
they were drunk texting
like they won the stanley cup and they
had so much booze
they get to that point right before you
pass out where you're just thinking of
all the great people in your life and
you want to start crying
so you start calling people up call your
buddy up who doesn't have a drinking
problem like two in the morning he's
freaking out that his [ __ ]
something happened to his mom you know
did she fall down again picks up
something like
oh hey
it's me mark i just want to tell you you
know
look i'm drunk i don't drunk but i just
want to thank you
you know i just want just for being my
friend man
that's what the [ __ ] they did
that letter of apology is a [ __ ]
embarrassment
to hockey and if this starts a trend
where every year i swear to god next
year somebody's gonna win and they're
gonna be like well no now we have to
write a letter of thanks
can you [ __ ] they wrote a letter of
thanks telling
how classy bruins fans are
can you just take that in for a second
i'm actually gonna wait
five minutes of silence to to wait for
montreal canadian
fans to stop [ __ ] rolling on the
ground laughing
okay you're back you blue blanca douches
up there
right i've been watching the bruins
since the early 80s
i'm going on 30 years of being a fan
never has anyone ever even remotely
suggested
that bruins fans are classy
we're a bunch of [ __ ] animals now i i
left
i left massachusetts in 1995.
okay so i there is a disconnect to me
with that city but
do you remember last year when the
bruins got knocked out of the playoffs
playoffs we lost in overtime
and that dude ward forget his first name
scored
for the washington capitals and
unfortunately
the dude was african-american and he
beat the bruins
and literally like an eighth of our fan
base went on twitter
and started dropping the n-word like it
was 1938
you know i don't know why i picked 1938
you know what i mean
and somehow within a [ __ ] year
we are so goddamn classy that the
chicago blackhawks have to take
time off from drinking out of that cup
that you know sh
[ __ ] chara took a [ __ ] in it
right i hope he did um
they had to take time out to see how
classy we are
now either the chicago blackhawks are
the biggest bunch of [ __ ] morons ever
which there's no way they are because
they won it
three years ago completely dismantled
their team and was were able to build it
back up again like the [ __ ]
marlins
right or
the chicago blackhawks and the city of
chicago
is so [ __ ] racist that even
that absolute public relations debacle
of last [ __ ] year that absolute
embarrassment that made me feel
shameful that i was from that [ __ ]
city
is so pale so in comparison to the
unbelievable
[ __ ] level of racism in chicago
that they didn't even notice it you know
i bet this is how racist chicago is i
bet last year
when they saw some bruins fans reaction
towards scoring that goal that they
they're so [ __ ] racist that that that
actually warmed their heart a little bit
and they probably already penned the
first draft
of that thank you [ __ ] letter i don't
know if you ever been to chicago but it
is brutally [ __ ] racist
you know as is boston but we somehow we
get all the [ __ ] attention about it
like the racism
is in the south and it's in boston you
know
like they don't go to pittsburgh where
the other side of the tracks
is literally the other side of railroad
tracks
you literally walk across railroad
tracks and instantly you're the only
white person
on that side of the tracks um
anyways that was you know
i still like the blackhawks but if you
think i fell for that on any [ __ ]
level
that letter of apology do you remember
earlier this year
where jerome mcgillner had the choice of
maybe going to the boston bruins
or maybe going to the pittsburgh
penguins you know
and it was a close decision and he
decided to go to pittsburgh
wouldn't you think that maybe
that horrific reaction that bruins some
some bruins fans to be fair
had after losing last year maybe tipped
the scale
because you got two great teams you know
i know a lot of people well i guess
pittsburgh is [ __ ] racist too but
they never they never get uh they never
get it
they don't get any press on it
you know all they talk about there is
they use this hard work in steel town
that there's no steel mills anymore and
anybody who had balls uh made steel and
built the bridges is at least in their
80s at this point so it's a bunch of
button pushing computer [ __ ] downtown
at this point but uh
they still wear hard hats to the game
um i'm sorry people like
that that [ __ ] look the end of the
day all that letter of apology did
was just heap more praise
on the blackhawks it was the ron
burgundy moment
i look good i mean really good
hey everyone come and see how good i
look
that's what they did
so let me tell you something chicago
blackhawks
organization and your entire fan base
you can take your [ __ ]
thank you your whatever the [ __ ] that
was that letter you wrote from summer
camp
you can [ __ ] crumble it up
how did that out of the rock used to do
that and shove it straight up your candy
ass
please don't ever do that again other if
any other organizations are listening to
this
please don't do that that that [ __ ]
just please don't do it it was such a
great finals
two original six teams one of my
favorite moments of the playoffs
was when that whatever that that [ __ ]
that i respect that pest on uh chicago
was holding up
he's holding up the [ __ ] stanley cup
and he's
still bleeding from the series
[Laughter]
[Music]
even in boxing they stop the [ __ ]
blood you know they got some guy there
pressing down on it with that [ __ ]
that compressed thing he's got his
gloves and [ __ ] and it's just talky
guy's [ __ ] bleeding and like it
doesn't even you know wait i guess ufc
ufc they could be
bleeding pretty bad i'm just look you
have to go to literally sports where
they're beating the [ __ ] out of each
other
um and by the way to all you [ __ ]
non-hockey fans
who still think it's the slap shot error
there was not one fight the entire
series was phenomenal
for all you [ __ ] pansies out there
you know sitting in your afghans while
wearing
aprons who wait for olympic hockey and
then lie
true hockey fans going you know this is
the way hockey was you know
i i would watch it no you wouldn't
you wouldn't because that is the way it
is you [ __ ] idiot those are all nhl
players in the [ __ ]
game you [ __ ] oh i am on a tear this
week
so there you go [ __ ] you chicago
congratulations
congrat you know what i should do hey
why don't we have a donation thing here
everybody [ __ ] uh donates money to
the monday morning podcast and i'm gonna
put i'm gonna buy out some ad space in
the chicago tribute
and write a thank you letter for the
thank you letter
so i can see somehow what a classy
podcast i know he says [ __ ]
every other word i know he can't read
out loud
but this is just a decade of the
robber [ __ ] losers
oh douche chills i got halfway through
the letter and i had to stop reading
i had i just stopped it was like out it
was like
it was like eating lemons and
there's no [ __ ] way how do you not
know how [ __ ] a [ __ ] move that is
it's actually hilarious if that's how
they meant it to just hey you know what
i bet they're just starting to get over
losing in the finals let's [ __ ]
remind them
you know what it's like it's like when
you break up with some chick right and
and it's like they women have that sick
sense when they can tell you start to
have good days
and you're getting past them so they
[ __ ] call you up
and just mind [ __ ] you all over again
all right i'm done i still can't hate
the blackhawks because i [ __ ] have
always liked that team and i've always
loved that uniform but
jesus that is a [ __ ]
it's i don't know what to tell you
they already traded dave bowling can you
believe that these [ __ ] guys
getting draft picks you're gonna trade a
[ __ ] guy
you're gonna trade a guy with ice water
in his veins
at the most crucial moment in the season
he's just such a [ __ ] great player i
think
i think the maple leafs got a [ __ ]
steal and i think they learned something
with that that uh oh wait a minute now
they've always been doing they got phil
kessel and they gave us a bunch of draft
picks but we drafted well
all right just wait strike all of that
but i think
i think the maple leafs got a lot better
and the blackhawks got a lot worse
i am not a big fan of draft picks
like hey let's take this proven guy dude
dave bowling he's one of those guys he's
one of those guys
those are the guys that when you're the
[ __ ] cup
you know everybody always looks at the
stars and all it's those [ __ ]
those [ __ ] guys like him
you just come in and [ __ ] knock your
stick off the puck and all of a sudden
he's got the puck right over the slot
and the big [ __ ] shiny superstar
scores
those [ __ ] guys in the corner i'm
telling you i wish the bruins got him
you know i'm going to write a letter
thank you to the chicago blackhawks for
getting rid of one of their best players
ugh blackhawks thanks bruins
city of boston in open letter
okay so basically this article this is
in toronto
they say the chicago blackhawks penned a
full-page open thank you letter to the
boston bruins in the city of boston
friday just four days after beating the
bruins
to win the stanley cup it's signed by
you know they all the guys
so they basically quote the entire
thank you and then the last paragraph
it's got to be about the bruins right
it's got to be because they're so
[ __ ] classy right
no it goes it was a classy way for the
hawks to
wrap up a season that culminated with
their second
cup in four years chicago won the best
seri
uh the best of seven series four to two
after gutting out a 3-2 comeback from
behind win in game six
monday in boston see what i'm say that's
how all of them were there was nothing
about the bruins
it had all to do with chicago you
[ __ ]
that was like a chick move i gotta give
you that was definitely
ah that makes it even worse
we lost to a bunch of broads
[Laughter]
oh my god dude that was right up there
that thank you i'm going to keep going
on this thing that [ __ ] thank you
letter was right up there with sally
field going
you like me you really like me
you know those moments be like oh god
you know that big drunk woman who
married the [ __ ] old guy
do you like my body
i'm getting uncomfortable just thinking
about it
gross [ __ ] gross chicago that
that letter was [ __ ] gross
and if if this was the intention to make
me feel this way
then hats off to you i'll buy you
[ __ ]
a round of drinks the whole [ __ ] city
i'll buy you a [ __ ] round of drinks
if this is what you wanted to achieve
that letter was worse than losing the
[ __ ] series
that's how bad it was
oh all right did i get it all out of me
i don't know
i don't know um where the [ __ ] do we go
from here
ah let's just just just dive right into
it so i've been keeping up on this
snowden thing
trying to see where this guy's gonna
land i'm rooting for
i don't know about you guys and i'm sick
of people talking about him like he's a
[ __ ] rat i think the guy i think he's
a hero
you know there should be more
whistleblowers
this is just an unbelievable [ __ ]
amount of power to give anybody
they got a great article the whole who's
watching the watchers
you know what i mean dude this is like
what this guy was working on that i've
basically
glanced over in articles because once i
get intimidated by how long [ __ ] is i
have to stop reading
um what this guy is [ __ ] working on
you have to understand that like that's
game set and match
they don't even have to whack people
anymore
they don't if they just have every
[ __ ] thing you ever did and ever
said on the phone text it's [ __ ] over
it's [ __ ] over
look at me what what office could i run
for let's just say i didn't do a podcast
but you guys know my sense of humor all
right
how arrogant was that uh you guys know
me i'm a [ __ ] loose cannon
what a douchebag um anyways i'm rooting
for this [ __ ] guy
right now he's looking to land i believe
in ecuador which is really hard when
even
everybody down to my level knows where
the [ __ ] he's trying to go
i think this kid's heart was in the
right place and i think he saw
what he was building he saw it for what
it was
as much as it could stop terrorism it
also gave
a bunch of [ __ ] potential sociopaths
an ability to build up
or absolutely [ __ ] destroy anybody
that they wanted to
and um you know that's just a uh
it's too much power if you if you look
around the world the amount of places
right now where people are protesting
because they are absolutely sick
of the people in power and how they're
running things
you know can you imagine being in that
situation
like just having a [ __ ] dictator
and the guys you know kidnapping and
raping and just gassing your own [ __ ]
people just imagine being in that
[ __ ]
situation like that's you know when your
life starts that's what's going on in
your country
and you got to spend your whole [ __ ]
life trying to topple that and now
you're going to have something in place
like this
where i mean everybody's got to try to
like start
an entire revolution by talk you know
sitting there with their hands over
their mouth like joe pesci and deniro
and casino
you know i think that arab spring they
saw it for what it was it's like jesus
christ these [ __ ] guys
these guys look out look look what can
happen with these social networks now
i saw a thing over in uh
bahrain or something these people go to
prison for criticizing the king first of
all you shouldn't have a [ __ ] king
this day and age
you know a king how [ __ ] old are you
grow up
get a [ __ ] job right so people tweet
hey i think the king's a bit of a [ __ ]
and they go to jail for a year i might
be paranoid but i think this is the road
we're going down
you know oh jesus bill you're in way
over your head i know i am but it's fun
that's what this section is every every
[ __ ] week now when i
when i uh do world uh when i do world
politics
not discuss them not read about them
when i do them
no seriously i'm rooting for that guy
you know and i'm a paranoid [ __ ]
psychopath so take it
for what it is but uh you know i see how
the average douche bag
you just he goes from nobody to being a
bouncer in a club
nine out of ten people human beings
can't even handle that level of power
and they become a dick you know
the next thing you know they're trying
to finagle [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of girls dressed like [ __ ] for
whatever particular reason just so they
can get in this club
and go in there and damage their hearing
and possibly get herpes
right isn't that the club scene man
all right two advertisers this week
everybody settle it two advertisers that
are going to change your life
and how you feel about it e-voice
everyone
all right look having your own
receptionist would be great
hell it'd even be phenomenal but paying
their salary
is really expensive that's why hundreds
of thousands if this goes into sweatshop
labor i'm quitting this podcast
that's why hundreds of thousands of
entrepreneurs are now using e-voice to
enhance their image work faster and make
more money oh good it had a happy ending
here we go
you can try evoice right now for free
when you go to the podcast page on
billboard.com and click on the banner
with an e-voice account as your virtual
assistant
you can get your uh your own local or
toll-free number and dial by name
directory
all your calls will be professionally
answered and routed
wherever you want evoice starts at just
10 bucks a month
10 bucks a month evoice even transcribes
your voicemail messages and emails
emails emails them to you instantly
just like with the real receptionist but
without the high cost
you can operate like a top executive but
stay lean like a startup and blow away
your competition
e-voice is even mentioned as a key to
for today's
businesses in both inc magazine and
forbes all right i think you should do
this everybody i believe in e-voice and
i want you to try it for free right now
for 30 days
for your free trial of e-voice go to
e-voice on
dot com promo code bill that's evoice
dot com promo code bill
or just go to the podcast page at
billboard.com and click the e-voice
banner right now
alright please do that can you please do
that for me
uh and when you're done doing that um
you're probably thinking like you know i
really enjoy watching tv i wish there
was a more efficient way to do it well
oat billy redface has the way hulu plus
everyone
you've tried screaming hit shows on your
pc on hulu.com now it's time to start
your free trial of exclusive content in
your living room
and on your mobile devices on hulu plus
with hulu plus you get total control to
watch
thousands of shows wherever you want
whatever you want
use hulu plus on connected tvs game
souls
blu-ray players roku apple tv pc
or watch from anywhere on your
smartphone or
tablet on demand at all times and with
hulu plus
you can binge on full seasons watch your
favorite current shows
and even full series runs of classic tv
shows
it's endless they got community modern
families south pack
snl jimmy kimmel family guy and more
hula plus is only 7.99 per month
but right now they're offering an
extended free trial of hulu plus
that is only available to my podcast
listeners take control
of your tv watching experience how do
you do it you go to
the podcast page at billboard.com you
click on the hulu plus banner for your
extended free trial
or go to the hulu plus dot com slash
bill again
click the hulu plus banner on the
podcast page at billboard.com or just
simply go to hulu
plus dot com slash bill all righty
that's the advertising for loose league
liberal booty
um where do we go from here
oh man i had a [ __ ] had a bad day
yesterday
i've been trying to drop weight you know
i got all the way up to a buck
85 so now i'm back into the 170s because
that's how i do it
you know i don't know about you guys but
i there's no goal in my life
that includes me wanting to be a [ __ ]
lard ass
i just don't want to do it you know
be that guy bending over to tie his
shoes like
yeah [ __ ] head turning all red
you know i don't want to do that
i'm going to be that guy rolling over on
my woman right
she can't even breathe so she's got to
get on top of me i still want to [ __ ]
do that
you know pushing my gut up towards my
face so she could find my dick
i don't want to be that guy this is like
a testimonial
so i've been eating pretty much as good
as i can
as far as like uh knowing what's bad for
me and sort of knowing something about
what's good about
about food for me good about food you
know trying to eat the right foods
just just just just bear with me people
all right i'm not a smart man
okay half the reason why i do this
podcast oh gives a [ __ ] i do this
podcast to promote me
and all my stand-up gigs but one of the
in unintentional
upsides this podcast is it really has to
make you feel better about yourselves
certainly you're you're reading out loud
skills did you hear the particular
moment where i i started mind [ __ ]
myself
during the e voice read but did you
notice how i went dave bolin
and i [ __ ] collected myself and then
i delivered during hulu plus did you
notice that
um anyways what the hell am i talking
about so i've been trying to work out
here
been going on hikes and each day i go on
a little bit longer of a hike
and uh these are the real hot months and
i wasn't even thinking
and i brought my dog out and went on
this long
hike and you know i brought her water
and all that type of stuff but i didn't
know a dog could get a sunburn
i know i know i just made a great
podcast now you're all going oh
she's fine but the top of her nose she
has little flakes on it i feel
[ __ ] horrible horrible and then
i think she was walking on the dirt for
too long and it was hot like she was
walking real
gingerly last night since she had a
flaky nose and she had a little tender
pause
do you know what it's like to see a
jacked pitbull going
is it walking down the [ __ ] street
and not complaining
still wagging its tail i feel [ __ ]
horrible
so this morning i literally carry my dog
like a baby
out to the grass and i let it do its
thing
and i carry it [ __ ] back and one of
my neighbors like oh what happened to
your dog and i'm like
oh you know fida i couldn't be like i'm
a terrible person
that's what happened because of my own
vanity
you know because i don't want to have a
head the size of a mini keg
i took my dog on too long of a [ __ ]
walk
you know i'll tell you what's great
about a [ __ ] dog is right now if i
asked her if she wanted to go for a walk
like her head would pop up she'd
absolutely freak out and she'd tough it
out again
because that's the level of loyalty that
a dog has
the kind of loyalty
that a cat would never have you know ah
jesus will you
you gonna do dog and cat material what
is it the 80s why don't you go upstairs
and go put on a blazer
pull up your [ __ ] sleeves to the
elbow huh
get some hair extensions so you can
actually grow a [ __ ] mullet
and compare the two
um yes i feel [ __ ] horrible but i
haven't losing weight everybody
my goal i want to get down to about a
buck 68 but i want to be [ __ ]
shredded
just one more time i want to do it all
do it me one more
time give me [ __ ] ass before i go
completely bald oh i want chicks to look
at me
and like my freckled stomach just one
more [ __ ]
time
i haven't had abs since the early 90s
sorry
um
you know sometimes when i'm in a [ __ ]
silly mood i i like to come out on stage
to that song to captain and to neil
like the second show on a saturday night
do that to me one more time it just puts
everybody in a silly goofy mood
i start dancing around like an idiot
girls put their head on somebody's
shoulder you know girls do that [ __ ]
when they just see somebody enjoying
life and they just go
i want to enjoy life too they just put
their head on their shoulder
all right um put your head on
my shoulder
wipe your makeup off on my
shirt it will never come out
you selfish lady lady
um all right let's get to some sort of
um oh this is kind of weird you know
because i'm trying to learn the uh
all the capitals i can go from [ __ ] in
uh
rikovic iceland however the [ __ ] you
pronounce it
all the way over to the philippines at
this point it's great now i kind of like
know where they are
i always get like uh
asia was a middle east was rough and you
think
about how many times we've gone over
there and we bombed [ __ ] that i would
kind of touch start to look at the other
[ __ ]
the other countries around there but you
just don't
you know you know what it is is wherever
you live that's what you know
gee bill that was really deep you got
any more [ __ ]
little i'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ] why do
you listen to this
huh um
no you know wherever you are you just
sit there and you watch the weather and
they'll have
at least in the united states of america
america um
white america what the [ __ ] who did that
one
that's one of those songs i listened to
like two seconds of it
oh by the way is there a white al
sharpton out there that i can call
for being offended i watched that
devious maids last night because i was
i just got to see how they're going to
get five years out of that absolutely
horrific [ __ ] premise
and if you can just see how they make
the [ __ ]
the white characters on that show i
swear to god
it's the f you got to watch it all right
devious maids put that on your to watch
list
you have to watch the white characters
on that show
it's [ __ ] hilarious they make them so
cartoonishly evil
like what are the the maids all the
maids are latino the whole [ __ ] show
really if you look at stereotypes is
probably pretty [ __ ] annoying
um so all the maids are latito right
they're working for these [ __ ] rich
white people i think they had one latino
couple just to [ __ ] level it off
just beyond evil white people so there's
one of them's like a movie star and she
needs to get a facial
and her latino made is can i say latino
one more time
her [ __ ] maid is crying
because she's trying to get her kid up
from like honduras or wherever the [ __ ]
they're from
but their dad died it's basically good
times set in central america
you know damn damn damn however you say
damn
it's spanish
[ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ] anyways
so
she's sitting there crying because she
wants to get a kid up there and
and the [ __ ] little white lady
is listening and you you're seeing
emotions on her face you think oh
finally they're gonna actually show that
a white person can have a heart on this
show
and then the person she just goes like
yeah so where's the father
and she's the father dead and she's just
like
oh okay well i can't give you time off
to
reach out to your kid because i have to
get a facial
oh it's a [ __ ] phenomenal show
meow everybody me [ __ ] yell
and i know that there's a bunch of
morons watching the show
you know from the latin community going
see that's how white people are
they don't take care of their kids
they're all rich and they're all getting
faith not saying every latino person but
i know
a good certain percentage you know what
i get white people deserve it then
because we've been doing that forever
right it's about time the stereotypes
and the ignorance came back around
to our neck of the woods you know what
good on you
good on you horny housemaids of the
[ __ ] oc whatever the [ __ ] it's called
devious housemates
they're devious everybody
you you [ __ ] pay attention when they
do that turn down service
you don't know what they're liable to do
those devious maids
um anyways let's go so anyways i've been
trying to keep up on
uh you know learning the capitals and
knowing where [ __ ] is
like all these years to listen to
[ __ ] bob sega
singing about kathmandu i didn't even
know where it was
it's in nepal everybody do you remember
bob seger
speaking of [ __ ] having that roast
beef torso
you know the buttons bursting on his
[ __ ] western shirt that's where i'm
going the cat man dude
i used to sing that in the world that
way i'm really going to
if i ever get out of here i'm going with
a cat man
and i i always thought i had okay
he's quote i always i thought it was in
like mexico
it's in nepal i thought nepal was the
capital of [ __ ]
india it isn't nepal's a [ __ ] country
new delhi is everybody
new delhi i always thought you know
would be that'd be a great idea for a
[ __ ] sandwich place
you get a bunch of guys from india from
new delhi come over here they started
deli
they make american sandwiches better
than americans and they call it new
delhi
you get it it's a new dell but after a
year be like why is it still a new day
um anyways
so i was looking up some [ __ ] and
somehow
i'm getting so into the geography i'm
starting to look up like
islands in guam and i remember you know
a few weeks ago when i was talking about
the spanish-american war that i thought
took place in like [ __ ] texas
you know and involved the alamo and then
i discovered that it was fought over in
the philippines and i believe
guam i can't remember in puerto rico
something [ __ ] nuts like that
something i don't [ __ ] remember um
so i started looking up on guam do you
know that they actually had trials over
there
war crime trials for japanese soldiers
actually not soldiers the the higher-ups
just like nuremberg
and people got put to death and hung you
know not a lot of them but they still
did
there was all kinds of [ __ ]
atrocities that happened over there
i had no idea i think basically
for the most part you can google any
country anywhere
and just type in war crimes after it
you know that's what blows my mind about
all of that [ __ ] and they've said it
before like what we did in dresden and
all that if we lost
like that when we firebombed that city
they were just like you know you realize
if we lose that we're going to be
sitting there waiting to get hung
you realize this [ __ ] and then they just
go you know what it's like a roulette
wheel
they just push all their chips on red
[ __ ] spin the wheel and drop the
marble
you know how do you sleep at night
running a [ __ ] war
you know just knowing that if you lose
you're gonna be sitting there with your
head down you know with your [ __ ] uh
headphones on
listening to people talking about what a
monster you are
the same people who did basically what
the [ __ ] you did
to a certain extent except now they're
they're considered heroes and then you
get uh it's the [ __ ] worst
you know and then those guys write a
letter of thank you for being such a
class actor and you're [ __ ]
during your trial um
so anyways there you go so now you know
people one capital i taught you this
week kathmandu though for some reason
it's spelled
k-a-t-h m-a-n-d-u
kathmandu that's why i'm going to cat
man you
um let's get to the uh letters for this
week everybody
and it's starting off speaking of war
crimes
speaking of death speaking of things
um what do we got here cadaver lab
it's a good name for a band that isn't
that good
you know meet some chick you want to
[ __ ] her and she you can't because she's
dating the lead singer of cadaver lab
and you're just sitting in your head
like going cadaver lab like
that's the name of the band let me guess
do they have a bunch of props on stage
of
people bleeding didn't alice cooper
already do that 40 [ __ ] years ago can
you just spread your legs and get some
normal
dick in you sweetheart you know
okay local heroes cadaver lab signed to
elect
records uh dear billiam i work in a
medical device company in southern
massachusetts
and i know you will be in the area for
your shows oh that's great you just
cross promoted my shows
that's like a jimmy norton bit from way
back in the day on opie and anthony show
on the opie anthony show the opie
anthony program
if you want to get official he goes i
see you're going to be in the area doing
some shows and want to see if you're
interested in coming into a cadaver lab
knees shoulders only no faces or bodies
but what the [ __ ] dude that's just just
like watching the movie trailer but you
don't get to see the movie
he said i designed a screw to repair
slash rebuild your acl i know you and
joe rogan talked about it
i didn't talk about it that's definitely
some rogan's
stuff right there uh i'm too dumb to
talk about [ __ ] like that
um this podcast is the exact opposite of
the joe rogan experience where joe
actually facts checks like [ __ ] did i
say my fact checks
[ __ ] i can't even get through this
sentence i don't i just sort of you know
overhear things and then i just
presented this fact
so anyways i know you and joe rogan
talked about it but
if you would like to see a jackass like
me try to repair
one in a lab please let me know you
don't have to touch anything
or you can if you want
let me know thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
you know what dude i think you've been
working in a cadaver lab too long
that you feel that you can just openly
invite me to this
i don't have to touch anything but i can
if i want like i just want to [ __ ]
squeeze somebody's dead knee that's not
attached to anything
why in god's name would i want that on
my hard drive
why would i want to know what that feels
like
to squeeze a rigamore die [ __ ] knee
sir are you like a serial killer and
you're looking for a partner
you know like that [ __ ] classic one
that i watch
where they they one of the greatest
lines ever
uttered on television when they were
talking about when the first
serial killer met the second serial
killer because he went to a new town
said move to some new town
there he made it he met a pyromaniac and
sometimes transvestite or a transvestite
and sometimes pyromaniac
that's how they describe this guy he was
a cross-dressing sometimes
pyromaniac um
and then they hooked up and they did a
bunch of murders together um you know i
do find that fascinating and i know that
your work is leading to a better good
for people who are alive
but uh you know
there's things in comedy that i i know
you wouldn't want to see so i would
invite you backstage during particular
[ __ ] moments
you know and that's what you're
basically doing
all right
now if you had the entire [ __ ] body
that that's another thing
no that's just it's just disrespectful
for me to go down there
like i'm going to sea world looking at
body parts
so that's what happens like when from
somebody uh
like donates their body to science
like they just take your [ __ ] yeah
we'll just take the knee like do you
guys go to like the butcher
yeah let me get a pork shoulder and uh
somebody's kneecap
they say i feel like working on acls
i mean it gets a great thing that you do
that just that you know it's funny i
have no problem getting cremated
because even for some [ __ ] up reason
you still feel it i mean it's gonna suck
for like 45 minutes or a couple of hours
however long it takes to burn you down
to ash
you know and as awful and as horrific as
that sounds
being slowly burned for [ __ ] two
hours
um it's over in two hours
whereas if you [ __ ] laying in a box
completely uh intact
full of preservatives you're just slowly
decomposing over 100 [ __ ] years i
don't want to do that
get it over with but that does freak me
out that you're gonna sit there and you
know
have my [ __ ] knee on one table my
shoulder on the other
you know so drew brees can
[ __ ] throw a better pass and that's
just [ __ ] weird
um you know what that was really [ __ ]
you invited me and uh i i didn't accept
and then i was a dick and i trashed what
the [ __ ] you do i'm come on dude you
gotta understand all right i'm i'm
yeah that's i can't do that i i preached
thank you for the invitation
it would just be weird i'd show up with
dvds there you go and appreciation are
you showing me this ankle
um married women hey bill
i know what i'm doing is wrong oh
ggs i'm a single guy who became friends
with the married woman at work here we
go
devious maids we have a ton of stupid
[ __ ] in common
we even like the same flavor chips i
know it's [ __ ]
uh we became facebook friends how did
you become
facebook friends but just be honest with
me you're sorry you wanted to [ __ ] her
and you knew she was married you didn't
give a [ __ ]
all right i've been there
um here we go we have we had like the
same flavored chips
we became facebook friends and little by
little
her messages started getting sexual yeah
and i'm sure you didn't facilitate that
on any
you you you weren't stoking those
[ __ ] flames oh whatever the
expression goes
you weren't [ __ ] blowing on the hot
coals at all right
you were just sitting there talking
about earth wind and fire and all of a
sudden she's like speaking of fire
my [ __ ] is raging right now for your
[ __ ] to be in it you were like whoa hey
where did that come from i
i was just talking old r b music
um it's at the point where she comes
right out and told me she wants to [ __ ]
me
she's smoking hot with no kids and it's
so [ __ ] hard not to do something it
goes against all my beliefs but i can't
stop thinking about it i have a feeling
she wants out of her marriage but i
don't want to be a homewrecker
i've also have to see her at work so
it's extra hard
to tell her just tell her to [ __ ] off
i listen to you every monday and you
usually tell guys to whack it and see if
the feeling goes away well i already did
that
and it didn't work i'm just an average
attractive guy
and want to [ __ ] her but like i said i
know it's wrong
can you just come to canada and shoot me
in the [ __ ] head
that's hilarious oh and he said from
scotland
no she's loving that accent
um all right dude not only gonna be the
[ __ ] a married woman it's where you
work
and the odds of that coming and once you
start [ __ ] somebody at work as much
as you try
and keep it on the down low everybody
knows they can tell by your body
language
everybody at work already knows that you
guys want to [ __ ] each other
they already know that so when you do
[ __ ] everybody's gonna know that
and then in six months when you go to
get a raise and you walk in there and
it's either going to be a
you're sitting across the desk from some
other guy that wanted to [ __ ] her but
didn't and is jealous of you
or b it's a woman who's jealous of that
hot [ __ ] that you [ __ ] and wants to
be as skinny as her
and is actually annoyed on some
subconscious level that you didn't try
to [ __ ] her even though she wouldn't
have [ __ ] you
either way it's gonna affect your money
uh
don't do it don't do it
been there done that trust me don't
[ __ ] do it it does not end well
all right you don't want that on your
resume it's awful
it's awful it's an unforgivable act
um don't do it all right you don't want
to do it your dick wants to do it and
this is a great opportunity to be
[ __ ] just steal from the seinfeld
show to be master of your domain
all right you don't have to tell her to
[ __ ] off just say listen
all right i would love to have sex with
you too but i can't do it while you're
still married so when that situation
changes
come by and knock on the non-existent
door of my cubicle
and i will put you right on my [ __ ]
generic plastic desk that everybody else
has
that was [ __ ] bulk ordered from some
staple somewhere
and i'll [ __ ] you in front of everybody
and i'll have my [ __ ] oh face right
over the top of the cubicle
and i'll [ __ ] you right here at work but
until then
get out of my crib what movie was that
get out of my crib
um all right wild bill
i'm 28 and have been living in japan for
five years
that's probably pretty cool what an
experience uh for the past year and a
half i've been dating a
fine specimen of a woman from your
country
but recently ended things well i'm glad
you did considering you you
look at her like she's something you've
collected in a lab
dude there's so many people who are so
close to being a [ __ ] serial killer
a fine specimen
you sound like one of those nazi [ __ ]
doctors
once that's a very fine specimen it's a
human being man
a large part of this was due to us being
from different countries her being from
the good old usa
me being from another guy from scotland
these guys from scotland are [ __ ]
killing it
i wish i could do a good scottish accent
i can't the only thing i can the only
thing i can kind of do
in a scottish accent is is the [ __ ] that
they said to me
where the [ __ ] the [ __ ] podcast um
and that was probably terrible right oh
my god that's more like northern ireland
shut up nobody cares
all right where am i going here a large
part of this was due to us being from
different countries and her being from
the good old usa
me being from scotland and our
employment contracts coming to an end
in a few weeks originally she planned to
come back with me but now i'll be
braving scotland alone
since the breakup i've been i've been
feeling down and generally acting
like a little emo [ __ ] crying drowning
my sorrows and worrying that i'll never
get with anyone ever again let's stop
right here
sir there's no wrong there's there's
nothing wrong with feeling like that
and addressing it and crying that's
exactly what you're supposed to do
that's what the ladies do and that's why
they're more
they they don't die as soon as we do
you can't push that [ __ ] down cry like
literally to not cry is you're denying a
natural emotion
it'd be like would you ever deny being
happy
or like you know i'm going to laugh like
i'm going to [ __ ] tough it out not
laugh
you got to let it out that's your body
trying to heal itself if you don't that
[ __ ] just stays in you
it just spoons around your [ __ ]
arteries i'm telling you
dude that was one of the greatest things
i saw when chris bosh when they lost the
[ __ ] nba championship
and he walked down the tunnel and just
collapsed and just [ __ ] cried it out
do you understand how advanced of a
human being that guy
is as a man that he could do that and
did it tv cameras whatever and just said
yeah
i was disappointed i just needed to cry
it out of me and i feel better
you know i think it's a great thing oh
by the way if yeah if you missed that i
was on conan this week
um the wonderful people over there had
me on the show again
oh jesus i'm an [ __ ] i'm not even
thinking here
um the movie the heat everybody
is the number one movie in the country
from what i heard i didn't look it up
but i
i heard it did really well so i want to
thank everybody for going out to see it
i want to thank conan o'brien and
everybody at the conan o'brien show for
letting me come on the show
run my mouth and uh hype the movie
i'd like to thank paul feig the director
for putting me in the movie and
everybody else
that i got to work with um it's
i i went to a a screening of it last
week it was [ __ ] awesome
a bunch of big laughs please go see it
um
because it would help me out and
everybody else in the movie would really
help it out so thank you to everybody
who went to go see it thank you anybody
even thought about seeing it
and uh whatever chris bosh was um
was one of the guests on uh on the show
and i was gonna say hello to him but i
always i always get like
a little freaked out before i have to go
do uh
panel you know it's like you gotta i was
trying to think like what the [ __ ] am i
gonna talk about
and i don't like going out there having
like
i don't know i like going out there and
just saying something
because then that sets me into just
being there rather than
you know like when you do that they do
these things where they they do like a
pre-interview
they'll do it on radio and everything
and then it just becomes this weird
phony conversation where you come
walking out there and they just go
you know hey bill have you ever uh
lit your foot on fire while mowing a
lawn and then i go as a matter of fact
i have i was mowing my lungs like it's
almost like the host
is has like esp you know what i mean
and there's that whole just trying to
[ __ ] fake your way into doing this
thing that everybody knows
you're gonna do so uh i always try to
[ __ ]
throw something out there and uh
and conan's awesome because he just
[ __ ] rolls with it i always have a
great time so
um and always get more fans by doing
that show so
uh thanks again to everybody over there
conan for getting me on and if you
missed it
i ret i retweeted the um
the uh whatever you whatever your kids
call it the clip there
and i'll be doing it again this week on
the podcast page and you can watch
my little interview there you should
actually watch the whole show it's a
great show
um anyways let's plow ahead here
uh where the [ __ ] am i since the breakup
feeling down crying but
however now that those feelings have
subsided
the real worry is not whether i'll find
someone but what kind of person
yeah i'm talking about looks here okay
i currently live in an area of japan
famed for its beauties
dude this guy is just crushing it this
is what you do when you're a young man
is you move to another country with
beautiful every country has beautiful
women you just move there
and all of a sudden you're [ __ ]
interesting just because you you're
asking them where the restroom is
just because you have an accent right
there you're going to get 40 percent
more [ __ ] if you even
remotely have any game it's going to
happen for you
all right i currently live in an area of
japan famed for its beauties scotland on
the other hand does not boast this
distinction and also has the highest
level of obesity
in europe does it i didn't notice any
fat people over there i mean i just
think in general
great britain just people have that fish
and chips torso
then again i am coming from the states
you know we go hard out here
um so what advice can you give to a poor
wee lady returning to a country of bad
food even worse weather and now also
finding himself having to wade through a
dating pool
of biological clock ticking tanning
challenge
third round draft pick ladies that's
hilarious
dude you know what the only thing i can
tell you save up your money and you got
to go back
you got to go back not only you got to
go back to where they have even
better looking women than where you were
in japan
you know maybe go down to the caribbean
or something like that this is what it
is
you opened pandora's box
no pun intended and you know the
selections that are out there see people
who never travel
they just end up [ __ ] somebody in
their hometown and then they get married
you know and it's just like they ate the
same food their entire [ __ ] life they
don't know any better
they don't understand how long
the buffet table is of ladies
that are out there you know like if i
was a guy right now getting i am a guy
all right but let's just say i wasn't a
guy
no if i was some dude getting divorced
and i didn't know where to turn and i
was a little bit older and that type of
thing
like that is what i would do i would
[ __ ] i'd go to
i get a personal trainer i would get an
unbelievable [ __ ] shape
and i would get my ass down to the
[ __ ] caribbean and i would find
myself some island girl
absolute stunning beauty who's on island
time
is completely laid back and that type of
[ __ ] right
and uh i would [ __ ] marry her i'd
find love down there
start all over again and just [ __ ] it
you know
and just give in to their vibe
start walking around barefoot start
chilling out
just relaxing going out doing your
[ __ ] job making the money
and then [ __ ] coming home to this
absolute
exotic beauty that's what the [ __ ] i
would do
rather than come home and go [ __ ] the
female version of you
you know that's what i learned through
travel
so there you go sir that's what i would
do i would get a job there
and i would tough it out save up some
[ __ ] money and i would
i would just literally google where the
most beautiful women are in the world
look at the pictures make the judgment
for yourself and then just [ __ ] move
there
you're young you don't have you're not
tied down what you can
always go back to scotland you know
but you could have some [ __ ]
beautiful lady on your arm
it can happen all right but you got to
take that first step sir
you got to put your freckled foot down
and just make that decision that you
know
you're going to bet on yourself and give
yourself a better life all right
god bless you good luck to you sir all
right girlfriend hits me
jesus christ howdy you know soul having
[ __ ]
uh can we stop with the hacky redheaded
jokes you know what i mean you know how
many times i've [ __ ] heard that
that we don't have any soul i don't have
any soul did you hear that sir did you
hear the wonderful advice that just came
from my heart
how could you say that you know what
just for that i'm not giving you any
good advice
i'm going to give you some terrible
terrible advice here i'm 26 and have
been dating the same girl for almost a
year
she's a dime [ __ ] like a champ great
job and family
sweetest corn syrups and the whole
[ __ ] nine yards anyways about three
months ago
into the relationship that's what he
called it everybody the relationship you
see what he did there
he took the p out put a t what's the
deal with relationships
he goes we get drunk at her friend's
house and she starts going [ __ ] nuts
running around i try to talk to her
and she slaps me right across the face i
was seeing red
but enough self-control to let it slide
in the past two weeks however
she has slapped me in front of my
friends and squeezed my nuts to the
point
of vomiting because i was playing around
and pissed her off wow
she squeezed your nut so hard you puked
were you drinking
he goes this has completely turned me
off and had made me seriously consider
dumping this bra
dude she grabbed your balls and squeezed
to the point that you puked
and you're still writing me for advice
how [ __ ] hot is this girl
he goes i'm a big guy and obviously
can't respond
so i gotta stand there like a dildo and
just take this [ __ ]
oh dude at what size do you feel like
you could come back with an overhand
right
although i gotta tell you there really
is nothing funnier than if a guy
slaps a [ __ ] he's seen that video on
the
on the internet with that woman slaps
that security guard and he [ __ ]
slaps her right back and she is stunned
for like a second and a half and then
just puts her hand up like a little kid
just goes
i am not pro-violence towards women
i am not but that is some funny [ __ ] and
i stand by it go [ __ ] yourself it's
[ __ ] hilarious
all right she got the old right there
fred
um oh right there fred for new people
i've i've told you what that expression
means
but before i do that i really need to
[ __ ] you guys are using cold lotion
incorrectly you'll be like chicago
blackhawks beat the bruins in six games
that's some cold lotion
that's not cold lotion all right cold
lotion is when somebody goes to do
something nice for you
and then they it's there's like
something bad about
it like nia said can you put some lotion
on my back
that's a beautiful loving nice thing to
do but i didn't warm it up in my hands
and i just put it on her back
and it was cold lotion you get it so i
still put lotion on her back her skin
wasn't dry
i did her a solid but the way i did it
caused like this [ __ ] jolt
this uncomfortableness that is the
definition
it's actually the definition of is up
on what the urban dictionary or whatever
it is up there
all right so the blackhawks beating the
bruins in six games
is not cold lotion because that that
would be like
they would have let us win on some level
but
also [ __ ] uh blew out one of our guys
niece
but they did let us win that would be i
guess i don't [ __ ] know
anyways let's get back to the [ __ ] shall
we so
anyways to to refresh your memory before
i went off on that tangent
all right she's slapping him in front of
friends
and squeeze his nuts to the point of
vomiting
and evidently um you know they're not in
the same weight class
so he can't hit her back he goes i'm
just afraid someday in the future i'll
go into
rage mode and end up crushing your head
on the stove
or something and ruin my life yeah dude
you have to get out of this
and then and he goes i might go into
rage mo's
end up crushing your head on the stove
or something and ruined my life
anyways love you and looking forward to
hearing you read this in your own clown
voice
um all right
well sir um you have to break up with
this woman
it's not even a question dude she quiz
she queased she squeezed your balls
to the point of you puking it's [ __ ]
over
it's over all right you need to dump her
and the problem is
you know what probably nobody has ever
dumped her and that's why she's so
[ __ ] out of line
so why don't you do it you know you're
kind of [ __ ] up now because you didn't
do it
in the moment you should have done it
the next day and just been like do you
realize how [ __ ] out of line no
no don't curse you just stay really calm
and just say listen uh
you know um i don't want to see you
anymore
i just don't i just you know uh
i don't know how to [ __ ] do it i i i
can't do it without cursing
you know you're [ __ ] psycho and uh
you squeezed my balls
until i puked and uh
you haven't even apologized you're like
that much of a dumb [ __ ]
and no matter how smart i
am my kids are gonna be
cut with your half a dumb cutness so
you know and whenever i see them do
something dumb
i'm gonna know that it's you and that i
shouldn't have dumped a load in you so i
uh
i i i just can't see it anymore
judy are you gonna when you break up
with you you're gonna be wearing one of
those dog
you know those suits you wear when
you're training a dog how to attack
people
a little beekeeper hat and a cup
no sir if if you're actually you know
having fantasies of slamming your head
on a stovetop yeah i would definitely
get out of it before you ruin your life
um
unreal actually and you know dude you
don't want to do that actually watching
the unbelievably depressing and sad
story of aaron hernandez
you know just watching somebody losing
their life
and then somebody else just throwing
their life away and that [ __ ]
depressing
depression where you're just like you
know is everybody's out there chasing
money you just feel like you know if i
had all that money
and i had a big house i would finally be
happy and my life would be perfect and
just seeing somebody have all of that
and
and just throwing it all away it was one
of the most depressing [ __ ] things
i've ever seen in my life
um
creepy chilling the whole the whole
[ __ ] nine yards
you know and this is how [ __ ]
hilarious boston fans are
my friends are calling me up going you
believe this hernandez story go oh my
god i can't believe it they're just
going yeah you know
what the [ __ ] now what do we do gronk's
always getting hurt
who's brady gonna throw to
[ __ ] it's like you know i think
there's something a little bigger
than uh trying to beat the dolphins of
the jets this year i think the fact that
uh
you know that people died that's just
it's unbelievable
i [ __ ] believe like if what they're
saying is true this guy
literally like killed two people in the
next week he's on sportscenter
you know talking to some you know
reporter then some lady they always have
they always have the ladies down on the
sidelines
you know and he's sitting there smiling
and waving and in his head he's like
yeah i just killed two people
um creepy anyways odd question
hey bill hey billy i've been enjoying
your podcast
and stand up for a while and have some
odd issues i'm a 17 year old guy
and haven't really been social or
outgoing most of my life
well dude you're only 17. i was walled
off too
um but recently i've had about three
girls start making advances towards me
and not really sure how to manage that
uh go with it dude just go with it
just take them out dude this is what you
have to do you have to push through your
first [ __ ]
date all right and the longer you go
the more [ __ ] more of a mountain it's
gonna seem like
it really isn't dude you're stepping
over a rake that's all it is
you know it's [ __ ] it's it's an
eighth of an inch off the ground just go
out there everybody makes an ass of
themselves when they first start [ __ ]
courting a lady just
take them out go to a [ __ ] movie go
see the heat i heard it's a wonderful
movie
um anyways he says and not really sure
how to manage that but now to more
issues
the one girl in particular who i really
like has been getting
pretty physical we had some pretty close
moments at a couple of sleepovers and
during the last one she started taking
off my belt
i gently moved her hands away and
brought them up to my chest level but
she's been more
sexually aggressive in terms of
initiating
stuff than me why might you ask
you probably would you get molested i'm
gonna guess
he goes why might you ask don't i want
to give up get up to this girl he goes
well i have a small
dick man
he goes laugh it up whatever go f dude i
would never laugh at you like that
having a big dick or a small dick is not
a skill it's just
luck of the draw uh he goes i make
up for it in character so not asking for
uh from experience because you sound
because from the sound of it you're
doing just fine dude i'm average
i'm [ __ ] right down the middle you
know if my dick was a car it would be a
[ __ ]
taurus no that's a full-sized car what
am i saying it would just be like you
know an ultimate
you know it's not going to scare you
it's not going to disappoint you you
know
it's a friend um
all right well it's dependable where am
i going here
uh do you have any advice what to do
i really want to be with this girl but i
feel like she may lose interest in me or
write me off because of it
and i'm destined to die a virgin i gotta
know what to do
and i can't ask my friends for obvious
reasons any response would mean the
world to me
thanks for making the world a little
brighter by the way you make people
smile bill and that's pretty important
some fans
some fan with the development issue um
though this is
a uh this is
this is beyond my
my capabilities other than to say like i
i would really talk to somebody
you know what i mean because this is
really like a crucial [ __ ] thing
where yeah you could be so embarrassed
or something like that
that it's gonna cause you to miss out on
being with somebody
look there's guys with little dicks that
get married all the [ __ ] time
who find love and that type of thing so
your situation is not hopeless
you know there's guys with [ __ ] big
believe me there's women with big dick
women pictures there's women with guys
with
there's women out there with big dicks
too you know there's just a whole bunch
of [ __ ] people out there everybody
and i don't judge any of them
there's women out there with guys who
have [ __ ] big dicks
that uh you know they're out there
[ __ ] around on them or they don't
have a [ __ ] job
you know there's it's not all roses
all right and after a while i swear to
god after a while
all the [ __ ] woman wants you to do is
just bring home some goddamn money just
have a [ __ ]
job treat me with respect and raise our
kids right
if you do that you're hitting a [ __ ]
home run all right
so um i would seek out some professional
advice
and then um
i don't know dude i i you know what i if
i had a [ __ ] little dick i would just
own it
i'd own it it just get it out there
just [ __ ] tell her right off the bat
you know
and then i would [ __ ] please her at
least two three times before i [ __ ]
uh
went to go do my business and uh
yeah i this i think that's just
something you just got to get it out
there
uh that's what i would guess but i would
definitely talk to somebody about it
because
this is obviously i mean obviously it's
bothering you would [ __ ] bother
anybody
and i want you to succeed you know
so that's what i would do does that make
sense
i hope that [ __ ] helped you out
what the [ __ ] did i do with my goddamn
questions here
it was still i'm the worst um
ah jesus not gonna look this up yeah
seriously dude i wouldn't i would never
make fun of somebody for something like
that you know what i mean
i would i pick on people for for for
writing thank you letters after
uh winning a championship under the guys
that they're actually trying to do do
us a [ __ ] favor gee jesus so swell
um all right let's get back to this here
so good luck with that sir
and um
where the hell am i odd question
yeah all right i did that all right so
there you go there's there's the advice
i hope that that
was a positive thing for you all right
because that's what i'm trying to say
i would that's i would never make fun of
somebody for like something like that
all right i think that's the end of the
podcast people um
what do i got coming up actually you
know what i'm not on the road for a
minute
i got some big shows back east
if you'd like to know about him you can
go to billboard.com um
i'm going to be at the cape cod melody
tent and i can't even tell you how
thrilled i am
to be doing that place like i told you
that's the place where the one and only
time i ever saw
george carlin uh so that's gonna be an
unbelievably special night for me
so it will be a a great show obviously
and then
uh i'm at the uh hampton beach ballroom
casino this is all the weekend of july
12th
and then i got uh the newport yachting
center
so like i said that weekend i'm playing
two tents in an attic
all right and that's the weekend of july
12th 13th 14th or 11th 12th and 13th i
don't have it in front of me but um
[Music]
tickets are going fast so thank you to
everybody who's been going out to my
shows and that type of stuff and blah
blah blah blah
and uh and with that we got to do the
outros here once again people if you
forgot already um
now the show's over don't forget to sign
up for your free trial of hulu plus and
start watching your favorite
hit tv shows right now watch tv the way
you want to wherever the hell you want
to do it just go to the podcast page at
billboard.com
and click on the hulu plus banner for
your extended extended free trial
or go to huluplus.com bill and also
don't forget
um if you're starting your own business
to set up your free trial of e-voice
join the thousands of honor
entrepreneurs who've used
e-voice as their personal receptionist
24 7 get your own toll-free
or local number professional greetings
have calls routed and all your
voicemails transcribed and emailed to
you for less than 10 bucks a month
that's really priceless everybody right
now you can try evois for free for 30
days go to evoice.com promo quote bill
or click on the evoice banner at the
podcast page at billboard.com all right
and with that i'm trying to get into uh
baseball everybody
i'm slowly getting back into it uh i
wanted to start watching the dodgers i
actually watched the red sox
beat the blue jays i believe it was
yesterday on the final play of the game
somebody hit a little flare i'm gonna
get back into it i'll get back into it
if the [ __ ] blackhawks would stop
sending [ __ ] thank you letters
reminding me of what i already know
you know picking that [ __ ] scab
um yeah that's it i've decided i'm going
to embrace baseball
you know i got a nice little time off
here i'm gonna lose some weight
you know take my dog on a short hike and
then i'm gonna go on the longer one like
what i did today
and i'm gonna get myself in great
[ __ ] shape here for the summer
and i'm gonna watch some baseball i'm
actually gonna try to go back east
uh well i'm gonna go back east i'm gonna
try to uh take it maybe a red sox game
when i'm back there i haven't gone to a
game in a couple of years
but uh that's what i'm up to all right
and that right there was the lackluster
ending to this
hopefully wonderful podcast once again
thanks to paul feig and everyone who
worked on the heat forget me in that
uh please go see it this week if you
haven't seen it already go see it again
or whatever
uh be helping me out and uh and thanks
to conan o'brien and everybody on the
conan o'brien show for let me come on
and uh run my mouth and hype that
project all right that's it that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and i'll talk to you next week
you